a lot of the people that are hiring the
gen z's
come from you know they're in their 40s
and 50s like that's the generation
they're setting the culture they're
setting the job descriptions
so
if you flip over to the the new
generation coming into the workforce
which is going to be a huge generation
this generation brings change
they bring empathy they bring
communication styles that gen xers
didn't have
they've all grown up on their phone
right they all collaborate they're all
into social media social marketing so i
would say you know bring your energy and
bring sort of the knowledge to the table
that will push change and make the gen
xers sort of soften up a little bit
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community community-driven vc fund in
silicon valley in partnership with
lumitec sponsored by home adventures
hippo insurance oppos labs synergy
global hillel at stanford leap
birthright excel serona partners and in
media partnership with c-tech
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today i am with mark
zeidz the founder and ceo of core access
consulting an award-winning learning and
development and challenge management
firm he is also the founder of patama an
agency specializing in sales strategy
marketing and customer success for small
to medium-sized businesses and recipe a
digital marketing agency for rental
event equipment companies he has a let's
go mentality followed with a positive
and all-inclusive demeanor because mark
wants everyone to enjoy what they do
where they are and the experiences they
have
mark is a connector who loves to coach
and mentor network and find
opportunities for those he sees
potential in all while maintaining a
strong family balance with his wife
three kids and two dogs
and you know in today's world where we
have so many different companies and so
many different
types of companies and different
leadership styles and different
growth opportunities and you know
there's a lot of it's very confusing as
to how to
you know internally and manage an
organization as a gen z how to grow our
own careers and the sort of strategy
that we should employ and how do we you
know get everybody in in the company
that we're already at on board with
different learning strategies so you've
had it hand
a significant hand to deal with these
different topics and i'm excited to sort
of unpack these things with you so thank
you very much for joining me today thank
you very much excited to talk talk to
you about uh some of these uh important
topics
well so let's start with core access and
tell me a little bit about the formation
of core access today close to 100 people
working with organizations
organizational development what what is
core access and sort of the the the
mission that you set out on when you
founded it
yeah so so we're a combination of um
really talented and smart learning
experts
instructional designers
program managers that
build learning experiences for
any company large small
startup
global
and you know the the content areas are
related to
you know any function within an
organization but predominantly we do a
lot of new hire onboarding you know
types of soft skills oriented training
and those experiences are a combination
of online learning so your typical
mobile you know learning or your
e-learning and also you know virtual
learning you know so in a in a modality
like this through a zoom or through sort
of an interaction this way you know
we're hoping to get back post pandemic
into kind of classroom based training
you know the old sort of uh face to face
but you know the majority of our work is
uh delivered virtually now anyway and
always has been for the last um you know
13 years
why is it
so relevant or or such a such a big
question this idea of you know the
developing the soft skills for example
for onboarding why do organizations need
a third party like core access to come
and provide provide these services
yeah great question i mean i mean a lot
of these companies have the capabilities
in-house you know to deliver this
training whether it's through hr or
learning and development oftentimes they
want to bring in experts from the
outside that bring some best practices
bring some unique points of view you
know bring some you know different types
of experiences for the learners so
whether it's you know
video based learning or
virtual reality nowadays you know
companies are looking for augmented or
virtual
uh as well as you know some what we call
impactful learning experiences right so
you know exercises or scenarios things
like that where
internal companies that have these
organizations don't necessarily have the
capabilities or the bandwidth to develop
these solutions on their own so as a
services provider you know we're the
nice um you know connection or nice
partner for for these companies to
execute these programs and then roll
them out to their onboarding or to their
new hires
how much is this you know the specific
or
tailored to to a given company so you
know strategically when you're looking
at these types of questions that you're
solving
how how generic are these solutions that
they're able to be replicated from
organization to organization versus you
know really creating a tailor-made
solution for for each specific one yeah
great question so every company is
different right sounds cliche but
certainly um we are a bespoke you know
custom content development firm so
companies come to us with a combination
of their proprietary content some of our
content and then we sort of bring that
together through a learning experience
or a learning platform you know the
company may have a learning management
system or uh lxp you know to host and
produce
and push out the content or you know
they may ask us to do that so it all
depends on where the company is
from a technology perspective as well as
a content standpoint but in general you
know most companies when we talk about
onboarding or new hire have their own
process and have their own content but
what they want to do is sort of bring
some other skill development or
leadership development work or content
incident program
i love it okay and and you know we're
now looking internally within core
access as you're
you know growing the organization and
you're providing these services you know
this is i imagine that it's a little bit
different than running a you know a tech
startup when you know you have about 50
engineers all contributing to a code
base here you have individuals that are
you know representing core access with
clients and with different solutions and
there's a lot of trust and internal
leadership that needs to happen
what what is that internal leadership
like
for you and and how do you think about
it strategically as a as an as a
critical part within corrections so we
are as good as our people and we have an
incredible team of leaders
project managers instructional designers
you know think about us as a creative
agency
for learning so
we are a one-stop shop for all things l
d and we want our clients to come to us
with any type of learning or training
challenge they may have and what we want
to do is solve for those challenges and
as a services company just like any
other management
development or management consulting
company you know we have a very high
touch model where you know always um
um you know servicing our clients to the
highest degree you know we call white
glove service or vip so we want our
clients to trust us as advisors
to give them the best advice whether
they're going to execute internally or
they want to outsource it to us as a
business partner to build these learning
solutions for them
i mean and that's a you know i can
definitely assume that as well and i'm
wondering how do you get the you know
the actual people that you're delegating
some responsibility to you know mention
almost 100 employees the each person
here you know represents core access in
these different situations how do you
ensure quality at this stage how do you
ensure because at the end you know
they're not just representing core
access they're also representing
themselves and how do they know you know
where is the line between themselves and
core access strategy and at the end
there they are both themselves and core
access right great question so you know
a little shout out to you know um my vp
of um talent management erica franzen
who's been with us for 10 years and what
she does is she
oversees recruits managers networks all
of these great practitioners so it's a
combination of people that we have
full-time as well as a very close
network of experts that we've worked
with for an average of 10 years so eric
and her team do an incredible job
managing that um i'd call it bench of
experts right that we plug in or we we
will place at certain clients depending
on what their client need is and then
christy delaredo is our vp
of custom solutions and strategy and she
also has a team of
you know project managers q a people
instructional designers e-learning
developers voice-over artists you know
the whole creative aspect of building
these solutions under her umbrella and
erica and christy work incredibly well
together every day making sure our
clients are really happy and they're
getting the right people at the right
time um to build these solutions for our
clients
so it sounds like one of the important
pieces you're mentioning is the matching
process is understanding who who do you
even have in your network
and
and and selecting the people that are
actually relevant and
we'll do a good job here
let's transition a little bit to to
talking about you know career decision
making and generation z
and this is something that you obviously
been thinking about for a while with
your recent book
what what is sort of the big pain point
that gen z's have in regards to their
thinking process
on korea i'm excited to say uh my first
book came out uh published by armand
lira press last week and uh it's getting
some rave reviews and thanks to my my
incredible team and network to help make
that happen over the last six months
you know what what we see in the
marketplace because we receive feedback
from our clients on what they're seeing
from a workplace gap perspective when
these gen z's or gen y's enter the
workforce
and what they're seeing is that they're
not prepared uh in general right so
generally australian speaking you know
they don't have the skills or
you know some of the behaviors necessary
to make an immediate impact at an
organization and what they need to do
and what this book talks about is
providing them with some coaching some
insight some guidance on how to prepare
themselves as they enter the workforce
as early career um you know uh people
right so they have they bring different
skills and and different mindset to
organizations much more than for example
i did i'm a gen x um you know the gen
zers you know care more
uh about changing the world they're very
they're very much empathetic you know
they operate and communicate much
differently than other generations did
so what companies are telling us is that
we need to figure out how to make sure
everyone collaborates effectively and
works well and the companies need to
adapt too right so when a company hires
you know this generation they need to be
able to
empower and motivate and and make sure
that they're enabling these folks coming
into the workplace to be successful
fantastic so so what are a few questions
that
you know that you're observing the gen
z's often find themselves asking later
on or or don't
are not intentional enough with
answering that leaves them confused if
i'm a gen z and i'm now preparing to
enter the workforce what are the what
are some of those non-trivial questions
that i may be asking myself
that that if i were to
take to be very intentional about them i
would have a much easier time and much
more successful time navigating through
right so i think there's a certain um
step process right so my book talks
about pace which is uh prepare apply
commit and evaluate but what i would say
is if i could break that question down
into two pieces one would be
make sure that you're preparing for the
right company in the right role so do
your research make sure that you're
prepared because again interviewing
michael is much different than it was
just a few years ago
students coming out of college uh are
interviewing you know through a zoom
right there's no more not as much
face-to-face um you know make a strong
first impression for example but once
they get into the workforce
they have to really do a better job from
what i see and what i'm what we're
hearing advocating for themselves you
know put yourself out there you know
sort of manage and communicate in a way
that
is um
you know
no i want to say i don't want to say
promoting your your success or what you
do but make sure you're asking your
manager you know what else can i be
doing or join communities in an
organization that can drive change and
impact throughout the organization so in
a virtual workplace it's much more
difficult
to do that make those connections and i
would just coach coach them on making
sure that they're staying connected with
their incoming class with their cohorts
as well as their managers and their
teams to make sure that
you know what they're doing is pushing
the agenda of their of their team or
themselves up to the organization
going back to the question of
preparedness
you know in today's world very volatile
we have you know we're going through
what some are calling the great
resignation part of this idea and also
career chain is this idea of being
opportunistic and and realizing that you
have opportunities that may come
at times when you don't even expect them
to and sometimes you need to jump on an
opportunity without being prepared
yeah great question so
i'm okay with the gig economy i i
believe that's not going to change and
it's it's it's sort of the workplace and
it's the future of work that said i
would just say that
i'd like to see these uh young and
career individuals be more patient
you know really try to
um
you know look reflect a little bit and
figure out is it the right time to make
this move or am i being a little hasty
should i wait and maybe give myself
another six months should i go to my
manager or the leader in the
organization and say
you know if you're not happy in the role
and maybe you can pivot you know maybe
you can be a little agile and say look i
don't love this finance role but you
know what do you mind if i try marketing
or supply chain or something else and
you can have different roles within the
same organization
you don't have to jump into another
organization to actually get that
experience you can you know
what i believe in is if you find the
right company the right culture the
right mission
that has the right values that map to
your own
you should invest in that company
and give it a shot give it just give it
longer than six months or a year now if
the company is not investing back in you
know to you
that's where you need to use the
feedback and give this company and your
leaders some some you know open
communication to let them know where
you're struggling and where you want to
move up in your career but i would just
say
you know the point is just be a little
bit more patient
i love it and so what i unders what i'm
hearing
is that part of it is this idea that
let's differentiate between
our what we do and and who we're doing
it with and we have to sort of answer
these two questions separately in order
to really get fulfillment and make the
best of our of our career and what
you're saying is that oftentimes you
know because of due to impatience or or
or the lack of differentiation between
these two elements a lot of people may
not be doing what they want to be doing
and they're also giving up on the people
they're doing it with even though they
may really want to be with these people
but this
clear association that a company is
essentially what you do in this company
it's that's not it right if you're
saying be patient invest in the people
that you're around navigate and pivot to
find what you want to be doing within
this company but again it's the people
around you that will allow you to do
this navigation and two moves and i feel
that one of the most important skills
that um the gen zers or even the young
millennials can learn is learn how to
network learn how to build your
not just your personal brand but the
people that you want to associate
yourself with in business so find a
mentor it can be many mentors right
because what will happen
is
in three years or five years you may
work at a couple of different companies
and those are the people and the
relationships you establish early in
your career that will really help you
further on in your career you'll make
you know hit the goals hit the
trajectories that that that you set out
for yourself
right what are some other questions that
we should be asking ourselves as we're
approaching different challenges
throughout our career so let's say we
have a you know we're in a great company
we're doing exactly what we want to be
doing where we're actually advocating
for ourselves within the organization
now what what what are we what are we
facing i mean it's a really interesting
question i mean i feel that every
company
is different right i mean if you're in a
silicon valley company it's probably
moving into our tech company it's moving
a lot faster than let's say a bank right
so
i would just say
you know that each individual needs to
evaluate their own
um
career uh and where they want to be as
cliche as it sounds where do you want to
be in in three years or five years you
know what i've coached
early and career professionals on is you
know think back to your your college
experience when you came in as a
freshman
you everything was green everything was
new you didn't know what to expect when
you were a senior and you look back
those three and a half four years
and you're you're a big person on campus
you have a much different perspective
you have much different experience like
wow i can't believe that i was
not doing enough when i was a freshman
or sophomore now you have much more
experience and much more perspective
think about that as you go into the
workplace in four years you can have a
lot more perspective and experience and
and and knowledge than you did the prior
three or four years so if you think
about you know sort of not just life but
the workplace in that regard it really
might you know uh shed some light into
kind of what it takes to grow your
career or what trajectory you want to
take as an individual
right and so fundamentally if we're
looking at the differences between the
way gen z's perhaps are experiencing the
world and gen x for example well if you
had to really
distill it to to a few key human factors
changes in the way that we experience
life and and and fulfillment what what
are what yeah so this might be a little
controversial but um you know i believe
that gen gen x you know values grit and
what i mean by that is you know we're a
little bit tougher when it comes to the
way that we look at business and the way
we work with people and i'm sort of a
blue collar you know typical um grew up
um in that way with my parents and
whatnot but a lot of the people that are
hiring the gen z's
come from you know they're in their 40s
and 50s like that's the generation
they're setting the culture they're
setting the job descriptions
so if you flip over to the the new
generation coming to the workforce which
is going to be a huge generation
this generation brings change
they bring empathy they bring
communication styles that gen xers
didn't have
they've all grown up on their phone
right they all collaborate they're all
into social media social marketing so i
would say you know bring your energy and
bring sort of the knowledge to the table
that will push change and make the gen
xers sort of soften up a little bit
right so i think there's an interesting
dichotomy between the two generations
um but that said
you know i believe that
you know
everyone needs to be more open-minded
everyone needs to be able to handle
adversity you know one one example i
always talk about is
a lot of times gen z's don't know how to
handle difficult conversation
because as they grew up they were never
put into a difficult conversation
because a lot of times you could just
text your way out of a difficult
conversation you didn't have that
face-to-face difficult interaction
where in the workplace that happened so
if you didn't have that experience and
you couldn't fail or you couldn't you
know do something when you were younger
it has to translate when you get in the
workplace and gen xers will look at that
and say
well they don't know how to communicate
or they have a bad stereotype that you
know they're they're soft or or they
don't take criticism well and again you
they have to debunk the stereotype that
that's the perception that some of these
you know gen zers have come in the
workplace and they have to do whatever
they can to change that perception
it's just reality you know in this sort
of world that we're in them
incredible mark i really want to thank
you and i love the insights and and the
way that you're thinking about this i
think there's some some some nuggets
here to take and especially definitely
for myself you know patience this idea
of fulfillment a grit
advocating
um being intentional and and
differentiating between people and and
and the decision itself and at the end
you know then with them we want to all
want to live fulfilled lives and we want
to do our best and to feel like we're
we're being motivated and we're working
with the people that we want to work
with and i think those are some
fundamental questions we need to be
asking ourselves and and and i and i
definitely agree with you that a lot of
times those are those are the most
difficult questions right most difficult
conversations are the ones we have
internally about what we want to do and
why do we want to do it and how much do
we want to do and with who and and and
it seems like a lot of times we we we
can easily forget to ask those questions
and and run away from them and just go
with the the path that was decided for
us so mark thank you very very much stay
safe and stay healthy and continue
making great impact with core access and
best of luck with that with the very
recent launch of your book
congratulations and thank you very much
michael
thanks michael appreciate you having me
thanks
you